no
[Música]
a escala en parís
braulio moro
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español recientemente el parlamento
europeo aprobó una resolución sobre la
llamada diligencia de vida de las
empresas en relación con los derechos
humanos y el medio ambiente si el título
puede parecerles raro lejano sepan
ustedes que les podría afectar en sus
intereses para hablar de este tema de
sus consecuencias saludamos aquí en
nuestro estudio a juliette reino miembro
de la asociación amigos de la tierra
francia responsable de campaña
regulación de las multinacionales de
dicha asociación amigos de la tierra
francia que hace parte de amigos de la
tierra internacional y les bienvenida a
esta escala en parís días muchísimas
gracias de acompañarnos amigos de la
tierra francia cumple ya 51 años de
existencia siempre con un objetivo
luchar por la defensa de los derechos
humanos y del clima es lo que explica
que está involucrada en una serie de
campañas tanto en francia a nivel de
europa como a nivel internacional tema
sobre el que hablaremos en esta emisión
dicho esto y qué significa esto
la diligencia de vida el parlamento
europeo lo presenta como un gran paso
adelante cuáles son las consecuencias
que esto tiene
lo primero es entender el problema que
tratamos de solucionar de atacarnos qué
es la impunidad de las multinacionales
se aprovechan de que tienen complejas de
cadenas de valor o sea cadenas de
producción y suministro con muchas
subsidiarias subcontratistas proveedores
en todo el mundo y se aprovechan de eso
para escapar sus responsabilidades
cuando violan los derechos humanos o
destruyen el medio ambiente haciendo
como si fueran entidades jurídicas ser
separadas entonces trata de atacar eso
la dirigencia de vida es un concepto que
viene de andría de los principios
rectores que fueron adoptados por las
naciones unidas en 2011 pero que son
normas voluntarias que son una
obligación para las empresas de
identificar los riesgos de violaciones a
los derechos humanos o de daños
ambientales en sus actividades en todo
el mundo
el punto es que la diligencia de vida no
es suficiente porque es una obligación
del proceso y que hay que atar la
también con una obligación de
implementar de manera efectiva medidas
para para que no se use en que no
existan esos riesgos
y también responsabilidad jurídica para
sancionar tanto la falta de prevención
de esas violaciones y también por
supuesto aportar reparaciones si hay una
violación o un daño que está hecho esta
resolución de derechos humanos y de
protección del clima porque ambos temas
bueno ambos temas porque están ligados
entre a de nosotros como amigos de la
tierra tenemos una concepción amplia de
los derechos humanos que incluye los
derechos ambientales y sabemos que por
ejemplo con nuestro trabajo mucho sobre
las industrias extractivas cuando una
empresa minera una empresa petrolera se
instala en un lugar primero es una
ocupación de tierra están acaparando
tierras de las poblaciones locales
muchas
sin consultarlas y violando sus derechos
humanos y lo otro es que la
contaminación no solo es un daño
ambiente sino que afecta después la
salud de las personas afecta la
producción contamina los suelos sientes
afecta a la alimentación etcétera antes
está totalmente vinculado de acuerdo
usted dice esta ley precisamente va a
obligar a las empresas en un cadena de
valor que es muy complicada se refiere
exclusivamente a empresas europeas claro
esta podemos imaginar esto cuál es el
peso tiene usted una idea de cuál es el
peso de las empresas europeas
multinacionales europeas hoy a nivel
internacional mucho sistema por ejemplo
en el caso de américa latina muchos
piensan que es eeuu pero hay muchísimas
empresas multinacionales también en
américa latina y lo que dicen los
empresarios o los presidentes de las
empresas multinacionales europeas es
nosotros cumplimos con lo que son las
normas en vigor guste hacia referencia
por ejemplo a los preceptos en esta
materia de la organización de las
naciones unidas si las empresas que sean
las multinacionales francesas europeas
tratan de mostrar que tiene una imagen
de responsable que están más
responsables que las empresas chinas o
indias etcétera la verdad de que
nosotros hace decenas de años que
trabajamos con comunidades afectadas por
empresas europeas que sea por total en
las cuestiones petroleras que sea por
los bancos franceses que financian
también a muchas empresas no solo
europeas pero también fuera de europa
que violan los derechos humanos entonces
es muy importante regular lo que son lo
que se llaman las casas matrices o las
empresas contratistas que están
instaladas en europa y que impactan
andrián con su producción en el mundo
entero esta resolución del parlamento
europeo va a seguir a lo que será
posteriormente una decisión una
directiva de la comisión europea en la
materia hay que decir entre paréntesis
que la comisión europea evidentemente
saludo yo su beneplácito a esta
resolución del parlamento europeo
concretamente cuáles son las
consecuencias y la unión europea a corto
a mediano plazo emite
una directiva europea en la materia
cuáles pueden ser las consecuencias
lo que hay que entender que ahora
estamos muy al principio del proyecto
porque va a ser muy largo
ese proceso viene también de la de la
movilización la movilización de la
sociedad civil hace dos años tuvimos una
gran campaña en toda europa para pedir
que se apruebe una ley vinculante para
regular a las multinacionales porque
como decía hasta ahora sólo tenemos las
normas voluntarias o los exactamente los
compromisos éticos que nos pueden decir
las empresas pero que después no cumplen
entonces ahora si se aprueba a nivel de
la unión europea después todos los
países europeos van a tener que
trasladar esa directiva en su
legislación nacional lo que hay que
saber es que nosotros en francia en
atrás estamos más avanzados porque ya
tenemos una ley que es la ley sobre el
deber de vivir y jandro así exactamente
cuatro años o sea por el 27 de marzo de
2017 que es la primera ley a nivel
internacional que
y responde que reconoce la responsable
legal de esas casas matrices en francia
sobre todas las violaciones de los
derechos humanos y daños ambientales en
todo el mundo pero esa ley ahora la
estamos probando nosotros estamos
llevando a cabo el primer juicio que se
contrato tal por sus actividades en
uganda y vemos que aunque esa ley abra
una brecha importante y es también la
existencia de esa ley que se que hizo
que es ahora se están discutiendo de
leyes similares en otros países de
europa y que también se está empujando
ahora con esa directiva de la unión
europea pero que tenemos que hacer es
aprender tanto de las fortalezas de esa
ley francesa que son muchas pero también
de las debilidades que tiene y que tengo
que corregir para realmente lograr el
objetivo para esta referencia a esta ley
francesa hemos hecho referencia a las
directrices de la organización de
cooperación y desarrollo económico ocde
en materia de multinacionales están los
principios rectores de la organización
de las naciones unidas es decir hay una
serie de instrumentos porque no han
funcionado porque no han funcionado
porque hasta ahora todas entre ventas
había son normas voluntarias entonces no
hay obligación no hay sanción si se
violan y entonces por eso nosotros
estamos pidiendo la aprobación de leyes
vinculantes tanto a nivel nacional
europeo internacional a nivel de la onu
hay un tratado que está en negociación
hace ya varios años que también estamos
muy involucrados en el proceso y bueno
nosotros creemos que esos diferentes
niveles se tienen que interactuar y
alimentar y obviamente tratar de aprobar
las leyes más ambiciosas que se pueda
porque enfrente tenemos multinacionales
que se saben adaptar que saben abrir las
brechas y ya lo vemos con esa ley
francesa que fue una larga lucha hacia
la adoptar y ahora la lucha es hacerla a
aplicar de manera correcta decíamos al
principio al principio de esta emisión
que efectivamente esta ley que puede
parecer muy lejana a las personas que
nos están siguiendo sin embargo puede
tener efectos para ellos algunos
ejemplos precisos y le renovó que usted
conozca de empresas multinacionales
con las que ustedes han hecho campaña
sobre que ustedes han hecho campaña por
ejemplo si yo vivo en marruecos o yo
vivo en argentina o en chile qué casos
nos puede dar usted de ejemplos
concretos sobre lo que puede tener en
consecuencia esta directiva esta
resolución bueno concretamente como
decía nosotros trabajamos sobre varios
casos y no involucra nada total que es
la mayor petrolera flota visitarán una
más grande en uganda están acaparando
las tierras de un androide tanzania de
más o menos cien mil personas y también
que tienen el proyecto de hacer pozos
petroleros más de 400 pozos en el seno
mismo de una área natural protegida pero
eso es no es un caso aislado ustedes
usted hablaba de argentina también
estuvimos hace unos años haciendo
campaña porque total tiene proyectos de
gas de esquisto de fracking en argentina
también afectando a áreas protegidas
afectando las las tierras de los
pobladores y tenemos muchos otros casos
hay otro caso después también chile hay
seguramente han escuchado hablar de la
catástrofe minera de bruma niño en
brasilia
ahí estamos hablando de una empresa
brasileña pero por quién está financiada
por bancos europeos entonces es muy
importante realmente ver todas las las
empresas que están involucradas y
cómplices de esas violaciones o sea qué
casos hay bastantes aunque sean
minoritarios con respecto a la totalidad
de las empresas multinacionales se puede
decir y se puede decir que hay
demasiados casos no sesiona min 9 media
obviamente todas todas las empresas se
hacen problema pero lo que vemos es con
las multinacionales que concentran mucho
poder económico que también va de la
mano con mucho poder político todo el
loving la influencia que tienen sobre
los gobiernos para impedir en riad que
se regulen eso lo vemos en todo el mundo
así usted referencia a un tratado que
está haciendo un negociado actualmente
en el consejo de derechos humanos de la
organización de las naciones unidas van
45 años que esto se negocia es
precisamente
lo que sería vinculante está en
construcción esta ley
esta iniciativa perdón que acaba de
aprobar el parlamento europeo que tanto
puede favorecer ayudar o contrarrestar
lo que es ese esfuerzo que se está
construyendo en la un bueno es el gran
desafío ahora porque en esas
negociaciones en la onu en la unión
europea los países europeos estuvieran
tratando de frenar el proceso de
bloquearla el precio de todas de todas
las formas posibles entonces ahora
podríamos decir bueno están ahora
detenidos el tema a nivel europeo antes
puede favorecer su participación en
debates similares negociaciones
similares en la europea pero el riesgo
puede ser al revés que digan bueno
nosotros estamos ocupados con él
la legislación europea entonces ahora
tenemos que esperar más para las
naciones unidas el otro riesgo es que
hay mucho mucha presión ahora en europa
para que la directiva que se apruebe sea
la menos ambiciosa posible hay mucha
fuerte fuerza de la oposición de
conservadora de las empresas entre ese
riesgo es que si se aprueba en europa
una directiva que es muy débil después
la unión europea va a venir con esa
directiva en las naciones unidas y
tratar que el tratado de la naciones
unidas sea también alineado con esas
normas débiles de europa bueno pues ya
lo ven ustedes es un tema bastante
complicado bastante complejo pero que
ofrece alternativas precisamente frente
a esta situación llegamos ya al final de
esta escala en parís no me queda
agradecer sino a giuliano miembro de
amigos de la tierra francia su presencia
de nuestros estudios gracias por
habernos acompañado a ustedes les damos
una nueva cita aquí la próxima semana en
otra escala en parís
[Música]
[Aplausos]